I mean is there something that stands
out to you about these hero organisms
like bees silkworms you mentioned E coli
has its pros and cons this bacteria what
have you learned
that small or big that's interesting
about these organisms yeah
the beautiful question what have I
learned I've learned that
um
you know we did we also worked with
shrimp shells with ago how we built this
tower on the roof of SF Moma which by
um a couple of months ago until it was
on the roof we we've shown the structure
completely biodegraded into then well
not completely but almost completely
biodegrade to the soil and
um and this notion that a product or
part an organism or
part of that organism can reincarnate is
very very moving thought to me because I
want to believe that I believe in
reincarnation I want to believe that I
believe yeah that's my relationship with
with God I want to I want I I like to
believe in believing most great things
in life are um second derivatives of
things but that's part of another
conversation I feel like that's a quote
that's gonna take weeks to really
internalize that that notion of I want
you to want or I need you to need or
um that that that it there's always
something a deeper truth behind what is
on the surface and so I like to go to
the second and
tertiary derivative of things and and
discover new truths about them through
that but what have I learned about
organisms and why don't you like E coli
I like E coli and and a lot of the work
that we've done uh was not possible
without our are working on E coli or
other Workhorse organisms like
cyanobacteria how are bacteria used
Death Masks the Death Masks so what are
Death Masks so we did this project
called Vespers and those were basically
death masks that was said as a process
for designing a living product what
happens and we looked at bit I looked at
the remember looking at Beethoven's
death mask and I got memnon's death mask
and just studying how they were created
and really they were sort of
geometrically attuned to the face of the
dead and what we wanted to do is create
a death mask that not was not based in
the sh in was not based on the shape of
of the of the wear but rather was based
on their legacy and their biology and
maybe we could
um harness a few stem cells there for
future Generations or contain the last
breath Lazarus which seated Vespers was
a project where we designed a mask to
contain a single breath The Last Breath
of the wear and again if I had access to
these Technologies today I would totally
re-incorporate my grandmother's last
breath in in in in a in a product so it
was like an air Memento so with Vespers
we um
we actually used E coli to
um to to create pigmented masks masks
whose pigments uh would be recreated at
the surface of the mask and
I'm skipping over a lot of content but
basically there were 15 masks and they
were created as three sets The Masks of
the past the mask of the present and the
mask of the future
um The Masks there were five five and
five and the mass of the past were based
on
um ornaments and they were
um
embedded with natural minerals like gold
yes yes yes and we're looking at
pictures of these and they're gorgeous
yes
um extremely delicate and interesting
fractal patterns that are symmetrical
they look symmetrical but they're not
this is intent this is we intended for
you to be tricked and think that they're
all symmetrical but there's
imperfections there are imperfections by
Design
all of these
um
all of these forms and shapes and
distribution of matter that you're
looking at was was entirely designed
using a computational program so none of
it is manual
um but long story short the first
collection is about the surface of the
mask and the second collection which
you're looking at is about the volume of
the mask and and and what happens to the
mask when all the colors from the
surface yes enter the volume of the mask
inside create pockets and channels to
guide life through them
um they were Incorporated with pigment
producing living organisms and then
those organisms were templated to
recreate the patterns of the original
death masks and so life recycles and
re-biggins and so on and so forth the
past meets the future the future meets
the past from the surface to the volume
from Death to life to death to life to
death to life and that again is a
recurring theme in in the projects that
that we take on but there from a
technological perspective what was
interesting is that we embedded chemical
signals in the jet in the printer and
those chemical signals um basically
interacted with the pigment producing
bacteria in in this case E coli that
were introduced on the surface of the
mask and those interactions between the
chemical signals inside the resins and
the bacteria at the surface of the mask
at the resolution that is native to the
printer in this case 20 microns per
voxel allowed us to compute the exact
patterns that we wanted to achieve and
we thought well if we can do this with
pigments can we do this with antibiotics
if we can do this with antibiotics could
we do it with melanin and what are the
implications again this is a platform
technology now that we have it what are
the actual real world implications and
potential applications for this
technology and we started a new area of
one of my students Rachel
her PhD thesis was was titled after this
new class of materials that we created
through this project Vespers hybrid
living materials hlms and these hybrid
living materials
really paved the way towards a whole
other set of products that we've
designed uh like um like the work that
we did with melanin for for the Mandela
Pavilion that we presented at sfmoma
um where again we're using the same
principles of templating in this case
not silkworms and not bees uh but we're
templating bacteria at a much much
um much more finer resolution and now
instead of templating using using a
robot or templating using a printer but
compute is very very much part of it and
the what's nice about bacteria of course
is that
um from an ethical perspective I think
there's a range right so at the end of
the silk Pavilion I got an email from
Professor in Japan who has been working
on transgenic silk and said well if you
did this this create amazing silk
Pavilion why don't we create
um
um you know glow in the light silk
dresses and and in order to create this
glow-in-the-light silk we need to
um you know to to to to apply
genes that are taken from a spider to a
silkworm and this is what is known as a
transgenic operation and we said no and
that was for us a clear decision that no
we will work with these organisms as
long as we know that what we are doing
with them is not only better for humans
but it's also better for them and and
again just to remind you where
um I forget the exact number but it's
around a thousand cocoons per single
shirt that are exterminated in in India
and China and in those Seri culture
industries that are being abused now yes
this organism this organism was was
designed to serve the human species and
maybe we should maybe it's time you know
to
to to retire that uh you know that
conception of of organisms that are
designed for a human-centric world or
human-centric set of applications I I
don't feel the same way about E coli um
I not that I'm agnostic organism
agnostic but but still I believe there's
so much for us to do on this planet with
um with with bacteria and so in general
Your Design principle is to um
grow cool stuff as a byproduct of the
organism flourishing so not yes not
using the organism the win-win the
Synergy a whole that's bigger than the
sum of its parts it's interesting I mean
it just feels like a gray area where
genetic modification of an organism
it just feels like I don't know if you
if you genetically modified me to make
me glow in the light
I kind of kind of like I think you have
enough of an aura all right thank you
that was I was just fishing for
compliments thank you I appreciate it
absolutely right and by the way the gray
area is you know is where some of us
like to live and and like to thrive and
and that's okay and and thank goodness
that there's so many of us that that
like the black and white and that thrive
in the black and white my husband is a
good example for that well but just to
clarify in this case you're also trying
to thrive in the black and white in that
you're saying like the silkworm is a
beautiful wonderful creature let us not
modify it is that the idea or is it okay
to modify a little bit as long as we can
see that it benefits the organism as
well as the final creation uh so with
silkworms absolutely let's not modify it
genetically let's not modify genetically
um
and then some because why did we why did
we get there to begin with four thousand
years ago in the Silk Road and and
we should never get to a point where we
evolve life for the service of mankind
at the risk of these wonderful creatures
um across the kingdoms across the
kingdom of life I don't think about the
same kind of ethical range
um when I think about bacteria
nevertheless bacteria are pretty
wonderful organisms I'm moving to my
second cup here
it's things are getting serious now
bacteria are yeah for sure